in 2004 my cousin Nadia was having
trouble with math she was in New Orleans
I was in Boston I decided to virtually
tutor her
it worked out and so I said oh let me
tutor some of other family members it
became pretty obvious pretty quick that
it was hard to scale that it was hard to
schedule all the time so essentially
just started putting videos on YouTube
2009 I started doing Khan Academy
full-time in the fall 2010 we got
funding from Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation and from Google and now we're
a real organization right now a
traditional classroom a teacher has to
deliver essentially a one size fits all
lecture pretty much guaranteeing that
some of the students are going to be
lost or some are bored students have to
do problems in a vacuum they come back
you kind of repeat that process then you
get a snapshot exam and then on that
exam whether you get 70% 90% or 95%
you're moved on to the next concept and
it's almost guaranteed to leave gaps in
your knowledge at some point your
foundation is going to be so weak that
will essentially crumble there's got to
be a better way to do this going through
like the high school experience when we
were trained for math competitions we
had a completely different way of
teaching each other everyone was
learning math a lot better in this kind
of extracurricular setting where the the
peers were teaching each other everyone
was learning at their own pace it was
really interactive really social people
were starting to make the connections
across subject area because you had to
have a holistic understanding when you
went to a competition the ideal
interaction is one-on-one you have a
tutor you have a student and the tutor
can kind of adapt to the student and the
reason why that doesn't exist in the
school system is that that's not
economic how do you reduce that how do
we give more resources so it's a lower
student-teacher ratio in my mind the
relevant metric is student to actual
productive time with the teacher ratio
we see the Khan Academy is essentially
the world's free Virtual School we have
the videos literally covering everything
from basic arithmetic all the way
through college level math and science
and economics the lecture frees up the
teacher so that all of their time is now
spent on these kind of focus
interventions we have the software
platform and we have a way for students
and teachers and parents to get data on
what's happening and for students and
teachers and parents actually
communicate with each other and maybe
actually even teach each other so we
actually see it as a real virtual school
for the world
you